Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Topkös, ich bin hier als Erzentätig und bin heute für Sie zuständig. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Ingamborg, Ingamborg-Bültmann.
Frau Bültmann, bitte vor und nach Namen Bültabir.
Ingamborg schreibt sich I-N-G-E-B-O-R-G. Ingamborg.
Bültmann.
K-W-Köln.
Ne, Borg mit G am Ende, Borg.
Danke, und nach Namen bitte.
B-U-L-T.
U-V-U-U-U-W-U.
Und zwei, Ü.
LT-M-A-N-N, Bültmann.
Frau Bültmann, danke schon, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62. Wie groß und wie schwer ist das aktuell? 1,68 m und ich wiege zur Zeit 80 kg.
Frau Bergmann, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerde haben Sie?
Ja, ich spüre jetzt so seit vier Wochen eine schnell Luftnot, besonders wenn ich mich bewege,
wenn ich zum Beispiel Treppen steige. Das passiert sehr schnell mit der Luftnot und in den letzten
zwei Tagen habe ich auch Luftnot in Ruhe. Wenn ich sitze, jetzt zum Beispiel, da muss ich schwer
atmen und das fällt mir sehr schwer. Ich habe Husten. Haben Sie auch Ausrüstung? Ja, etwas,
etwas so schleimig, etwas weislich, schleimig, aber nicht zu viel. Wie sagt das aus Wolfs, grünig oder weiss?
Weiß, weißlich und schleimig. Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden? Nein, so was habe ich so noch nie
gehabt. Vor sechs Wochen hatte ich Corona, eine Corona-Infektion. Da musste ich auch einige Tage im
Bett liegen und seitdem habe ich mich auch nicht wieder richtig erholt. Seit wann ist es wieder richtig
gut nach dem Corona-Enzen? Gar nicht gut. Corona wurde es eigentlich gar nicht gut. Vor sechs Wochen
war Corona und seit vier Wochen habe ich die Luftnot, wenn ich Treppen steigen muss, aber seit zwei
Tagen auch in Ruhe. Ich tut mich sehr leid, Frau Bördmann. Haben Sie Fieber? Nein, Fieber habe ich
nicht. Haben Sie auch Herzrasen, Herzstoppen oder Herzkörper? Ich glaube, mein Herz schlägt etwas
schneller als sonst, aber im Herz Stolpern habe ich nicht bemerkt. Haben Sie auch Brustschmerzen?
Nein. Okay, keine Brustschmerzen. Sie haben schon gesagt Atomnot und Auswurf Brusten,
haben Sie schon bemerkt in Ihren Beinen Schwillungen? Ja, das habe ich bemerkt. In den letzten Tagen
sind die Beine ziemlich dick geworden, besonders zum Abend hin. Am Abend sind sie sehr dick,
sind sie wieder etwas dünner, aber ich muss auch in der Nacht häufiger jetzt aufstehen und
Wasser lassen. Wie viel mal? Fünf mal. Aber früher nicht, nur sechs Wochen. Früher höchstens einmal.
Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen? Ich meine Bluthochdruck, Blutzucker, Herzschweche,
Beispiel? Ja, ja, ich habe hohen Blutdruck seit zehn Jahren und dann nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Was nehmen Sie? Gar keine. Ich nehme einmal Kandisatana, heißt das. Hintersteht acht.
Da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und abends eine Tablette und dann nehme ich noch ein Medikament,
das heißt Bisoprolol. Da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und auch abends eine.
Da hinter steht fünf. Da nehme ich noch eine Tablette, die soll das Wasser aus dem Körper treiben.
Das ist ein schwieriger Name, der heißt Frosemith.
Vorruf steht dahinter 40. Da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Wann waren Ihre letzten Blutdruckwerte? Ist das gut angestellt?
Ich messe zu Hause auch den Blutdruck. Da habe ich vor einer Woche vielleicht gemessen.
Da war er bei 135 zu 90. Das fand ich eigentlich ganz gut für mich. Er war auch
schon mal etwas höher. Aber ich war jetzt vor acht Wochen bei meinem Hausarzt zur Kontrolle
wegen meinem Zucker. Da war der Blutdruck in Ordnung. Da war der Hausarzt zufrieden.
Okay, sehr gut. Leiden Sie auch Leitezucker? Ja, ich habe Zucker seit zwei Jahren,
ist der bekannt. Da muss ich auch eine Tablette nehmen.
Mit Formin? Da nehme ich mit Formin. Dahinter steht 850. Da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und abends eine halbe.
Eine halbe, okay. Wie war das, Ihre letzten Blutdruckwerte? Ist das gut angestellt?
Der Langzeitwert wird ja immer kontrolliert.
Der Langzeitwert, sagte der Arzt, der wäre ganz gut.
Er war etwas unter sieben. Super. Da war ich sehr zufrieden mit.
Ich versuche auch mich von der Ernährung her zu zurechten.
Aber in letzter Zeit, kaum ist.
Das ging mir nicht so gut.
Ja, vielleicht haben Sie auch kaum Appetit.
Appetit ist nicht so gut, aber trotzdem habe ich Gewicht zugenommen.
Wie viel Kilo haben Sie zugenommen?
Ich würde sagen, in den letzten Wochen waren das fünf Kilo.
Nur eine Woche?
Nein, die letzten vier Wochen, seitdem ich diese Luftnot habe.
Okay, vier Wochen.
Fünf Kilo zugenommen.
Frau Böchtmann, haben Sie Probleme?
Sie haben in der Nacht Wasser lassen.
Auch tagsüber haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser lassen und Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung.
Ich hatte vor einem Jahr eine Darmspiegelung.
Vorsorge-Darmspiegelung, da war auch alles in Ordnung.
Vorsorge-Darm.
Und Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung.
Wasser lassen, ich muss tagsüber auch etwas mehr Wasser lassen.
Ich glaube, das kommt von dieser Wassertablette.
Aber besonders viel Wasser lassen muss ich nachts.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich schlapp für Müdigkeit?
Ja, ich fühle mich schon ziemlich schlapp und müde.
Ich neige immer wieder dazu, einzuschlafen.
Keine Energie.
Die Arbeit fällt mir auch schwer.
Was machen Sie bei der Pflicht?
Ich bin Sekretärin bei einem Rechtsanwalt.
Haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit?
Ja, besonders jetzt, wo ich mich eben so müde und schlapp fühle.
Da fühle ich mich nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Wegen dieser Krankheit hat sie Müde und deswegen Stress.
Normalerweise?
Ja, ja.
Es ist viel Arbeit, aber wie gesagt, ich konnte das früher besser.
Okay, verstehe.
Frau Bördmann, Sie haben am Haupt-Bericht
die Haupt-Beschleure der Atemnot.
Und zusammen begleitet die Husten und den Auswurf.
Aber Sie fühlen sich müde.
Sie können auch in Ruhe Atemnot.
Sie können nicht so gut laufen wegen dieser Atemnot,
aber keine Burgoschmerzen.
Parallel haben Sie Herzschläufe, Herzrasen.
Sie haben gesagt, kaum Appetit, aber 5 kg zugenommen haben.
Aber Sie haben keine Fieber.
Nein, ich habe aber auch kein Herzrasen.
Ich glaube, der Puls ist etwas schneller als normal.
Aber Herzrasen habe ich nicht.
Okay, Puls ist etwas schneller.
Wie ist Ihren Haut?
Ist das auch trochene Haut?
Ich habe immer trockenen Haut.
In den letzten Jahren muss ich immer etwas einfetten mit Fettcreme machen.
Ihr Haut ist immer etwas trocken.
Ja, seit wann, ich höre nicht.
Ihr Haut ist trocken schon seit einigen Jahren.
Seit einigen Jahren.
Okay, Frau Bördmann, haben Sie bemerkt,
dass die Stürmer oder die Krüfte vergrößert sind?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Da ist nichts größer geworden.
Sind Sie nicht verstopf?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sind Sie wechseljahrelang?
Ja, ich glaube, mein Klimakterium ist schon vorbei.
Ich habe keine Periode mehr.
Seit?
Seit 3-4 Jahren.
Wann war Ihre letzte Frau?
Frau und Herzin gehe ich einmal im Jahr.
Da war ich zuletzt im März.
Es war alles in Ordnung, oder?
Ja, alles in Ordnung.
Hatten Sie wegen dieser Atemnot,
in Hausarzt oder Kardiologen besucht?
Beim Kardiologen war ich noch nie.
Hausarzt, das ist demnächst wieder in,
das ist sogar zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr,
ist ein Termin für meine Zuckerkontrolle.
Ich dachte, ich war, kann so lange warten.
Aber jetzt ist das mit der Luftnot doch schlimmer geworden.
Deswegen bin ich heute in der Krüfte gekommen.
Ja, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, zu uns kommen.
Frau Bördmann, Sie haben gesagt,
Bluthochdruck und Altezucker,
haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen, Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, sonst nicht.
Sie haben schon gesagt, mit Formin nehmen Sie,
kann der Sarter bis zur Prolofrosomit.
Sonst noch etwas nehmen Sie regelmäßig?
Nein, sonst nehme ich nichts.
Sind Sie, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind, da war ich vielleicht,
so acht oder neun Jahre alt, da wurde ich am Nabelbruch operiert.
Und zwei Jahre später, weil ich war 12,
wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert.
Ein Nabelbruch operiert? Ja.
Sie war neun Jahre alt? Ja, ich war neun Jahre alt.
Mit zwölf Jahren wurde ich an den Mandeln operiert.
Und vor zwölf Jahren, genau vor zwölf Jahren,
also das war, ich war 12 Jahre alt,
vor zwölf Jahren, also da war ich 50,
da wurde mir die Gallenblase entfernt,
weil ich hatte vorher eine Bauspeicheldrysenentzündung.
Da war ein Gallenstein,
wohl hatte sich im Gallengang eingeklemmt,
oder das hat dann zu einer Bauspeicheldrysenentzündung geführt.
Okay, wegen dieser Gallenblasenstein,
das ist passiert? Ja, ja.
Und dann wurde ich einige Wochen später dann operiert.
Okay, Sie haben schon gesagt, 15 Jahre Gallenblasen operiert.
Ja, vor zwölf Jahren, da war ich 50 Jahre alt,
mit mir nicht 62.
62, gerade Sie war 50 Jahre alt, Gallenblase-Oppe.
Und wurde Sie auch Bauspeicheldrysen-Oppe?
Nein, die Bauspeicheldrysenentzündung war einige Wochen vorher.
Ja, und Sie haben ein Stein,
da irgendwo in einem Gang und hat dazu geführt,
dass die Bauspeicheldryse sich entzündet hat.
Okay, wie wurde diese Bauspeicheldrysenentzündung
mit Gallenblasenentzündung,
Diagnose, mit einem Schleim?
Ja, da wurde damals Computertomographie gemacht
und ein Schlauch musste ich schlucken.
Und dann wurde das festgestellt.
Okay, vielleicht.
Sonst noch etwas, diese andere...
Nein, sonst wurde ich nicht mehr operiert, diese Operation.
Ich möchte fragen, wurden Sie diese Operation...
Komplikationslosung...
Ja, das ist alles gut verlaufen.
Oh, super. Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Und haben Sie Unverzweidriglichkeiten?
Nein, ich achte drauf beim Essen, auch wegen meinem Zucker.
Da achte ich drauf ein bisschen,
dass ich dementsprechend hatte,
eine Verratung bei der Diätassistentin
und versuche da, das einzuhalten.
Und ich kann eigentlich alles vertragen.
Okay, super.
Haben Sie auch keine Medikamentealertik?
Nein.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie sind Sekretärin
in Recht anwärts.
Ja.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder, die sind 30 Jahre alt und 32 Jahre,
die sind gesund, ja.
Erwachsene Kinder.
Ja.
Wo nun Sie mit Ihrem Fraa zusammen,
Mann zusammen?
Ich wohne nur mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Die Kinder wohnen in anderen Städten.
Sie sind schon eigene Familien teilweise.
Okay.
Wie bin Ihr eigentlich noch?
Die Mutter lebt noch, die Mutter ist 86 Jahre alt.
Die Mutter hat Asthma und hat schwere Arthose
in beiden Kniegelenken,
sodass sie ganz schlecht laufen kann.
Sie geht am Rolator.
Der Vater ist mit im Alter von 76 Jahren verstorben.
Der hatte eine Herzschwäche.
Oh, wegen Herzschwäche.
Okay.
Es tut mir sehr leid, Mann.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie geht mit Rolator?
Ja, sie geht mit Rolator,
weil sie die Knie machen,
so kann man nicht drauf.
Okay, verstehe.
Sind Sie einzig Kind?
Nein, ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Der ist 60 Jahre alt.
Der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Okay.
Sonst aber ist er gezwungen.
Sonst ist er...
Okay.
Sind Sie fürständig gegen Corona?
Ja, bin ich.
Ich habe jetzt nur keine Impfung bekommen,
weil ich gerade vor sechs Wochen wieder Corona hatte.
Okay.
Wie viele Mal...
Ich verstehe nicht, wie viele Mal sind Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Fünf Mal.
Oh, fünf Mal.
Okay.
War Sie in nächster Zeit ins Ausland gewesen?
Nein, nein.
Aber mache ich immer an der Ostsee.
Ostsee, ja.
Wie lange dauert diese?
Nein, diese...
Die Reise?
Reise, ich meine.
Die Reise an die Ostsee mit dem Auto vier Stunden?
Vier Stunden ungefähr.
Okay, super.
Haben Sie Traum oder Verletzungen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Keine.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, habe ich früher gemacht.
Aber in letzter Zeit bin ich da faul geworden.
Früher habe ich viel Gymnastik gemacht.
Hab früher auch mal Volleyball gespielt.
Aber in den letzten Jahren bin ich da sehr träge geworden.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Frau Bertmann, ich denke, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestärkt.
Möchten Sie etwas zufrieden oder möchten Sie etwas fragen?
Ja, muss und muss.
Ich muss...
Also, was mir noch auffällt, ist, dass ich seit einiger Zeit
auch so ein Druckgefühl im Bauch habe,
unter dem Rippenbogen, auf der rechten Seite.
Das habe ich so ein Spannungsgefühl.
Das ist mir aufgefallen, auf der rechten Seite im Bauch.
Können Sie wiederholen?
Ich verstehe nicht.
Rechten Seite im Bauch?
Ja, so ein Druckgefühl.
Als ob da etwas zu viel ist.
Als ob da jemand da drückt.
Ein Druckgefühl.
Mein Mann ist noch aufgefallen, dass ich häufig so blaue Lippen habe.
Rechte Seite im Bauch?
Ja.
Seit von?
Ja, unterhalb von den Rippen, wo der Rippenbogen ist.
Da spüre ich das.
Rippen, ja.
Rechte Seite im Bauch, Druckgefühl, unterhalb von Rippen.
Und Sie sind Ihren Lippen ein bisschen blau.
Mein Mann ist aufgefallen, der sagt,
du hast in letzter Zeit oft so blaue Lippen.
Blaue Lippen.
Interessant.
Sie haben schon Gallenblase operiert, oder?
Ja, die Gallenblase ist schon operiert worden vor zwölf Jahren.
Okay.
Ja, ich möchte auch fragen, rachen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Oh, super.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber auch nach dieser Bauchspeichodrösenentzündung,
hat man mir auch gesagt,
muss ich sehr vorsichtig sein.
Ich habe aber nie viel Alkohol.
Aber ich trinke jetzt vielleicht mal in der pro Woche ein Glas Wein.
Ja, das ist, was geht.
Aber früher viel?
Früher war es mehr, aber es war jetzt nicht jeden Tag.
Okay.
Und nimm Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich, es ist ein Routine.
Nimm Sie Drogen, ich denke nicht darüber.
Nein, nein, habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Okay, verstehe.
Rechte Seite im Bauch, Druckgefühl, unterhalb von Rippen.
Ich denke, Sie haben eine herzliche Woche.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich brauche einige Untersuchungen,
körperliche Untersuchungen, Laborunternehmen,
und auch die
Elektro-Kardiografie und Bach-Ultraschall.
Okay.
Danach werde ich eine richtige und feste Diagnose stellen.
Sie sollten bitte Geduld haben.
Dann werde ich eine richtige Diagnose sagen.
Aber vor dem diese Köpfer, ich muss zuerst
körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich habe eine Fremd, ich habe eine Scham.
Gut, das können wir machen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt ja etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Versuchen Sie jetzt, die Patientensprache zu übersetzen
in medizinische Fachbegriffe.
Ja?
Die Begriffe für Luftnot, für Belastungsluftnot,
für Wasseransammlung in den Beinen usw.
Die Kollegen und Kolleginnen, die zugehört haben,
zugeschaut haben, einige haben Kommentare geschrieben,
habe ich gesehen, können ja gerne noch Ergänzungsfragen stellen,
wenn wir etwas noch nicht gefragt worden ist oder so.
Aber da würde ich darum bitten,
wenn da noch Ergänzungsfragen sind.
Dann haben Sie eine Ständig-Frage.
Bitte.
Darf ich etwas fragen?
Bitte, ja.
Leitern Sie in den letzten Wochen
an Konzentrationsstörungen
oder fühlen Sie sich Probleme weiter konzentrieren?
Ja, dadurch, dass ich so schlapp bin und so müde bin
und mich nicht mehr so belastungsfähig fühle,
habe ich auch dann mit Unterkonzentrationsstörungen bestimmt.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Blau liebend haben.
Das ist meine Mann aufgefallen.
Ist Ihnen auch oder ist Ihre Mann aufgefallen,
ob Ihr Fingergruppen auch Blau sind?
Da hat er nichts von gesagt.
Ist mir jetzt aber auch so nicht aufgefallen.
Er hat Sprache immer von meinen Lippen, dass die so Blau sind.
Können Sie etwas in Ihrem Retten oder auftasten?
Oder ist das nur ein Druckgefühl?
Ich habe da noch nie getastet.
Aber es ist so ein komisches Druckgefühl.
Also, ob da irgendetwas ist, das war vorher so nicht.
Ja, verstanden, danke.
Hat sich verändert.
Ich habe eigene Frage.
Ist Ihnen die Ergrößerung des Bauchsparks aufgefallen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Aber insgesamt habe ich mehr Körpergewicht.
Jetzt diese 5 kg, insgesamt gesehen,
ist mein Bauch vielleicht etwas dicker geworden.
Aber besonders sind die Beine dicker geworden.
Können Sie flach liegen?
Früher konnte ich das.
Aber seit 4 Wochen brauche ich mindestens 2 Kissen.
Und die letzten 2 Tage, wo ich auch in Ruhe die Luftnot habe,
habe ich immer im Sessel geschlafen.
Da ist mir eine Frage.
Wie viele Leckkissen benutzt man Sie beim Schlafen?
Bis vor 2 Tagen waren das 2 Kissen.
Und in den letzten beiden Nächten habe ich, wie gesagt,
im Sessel geschlafen.
Da konnte ich auch nicht mehr mit den 2 Kissen liegen.
Das war mir zu flach.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit auch Verdankprobleme gebläht?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie keine Übelkeit und Erbrochen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht.
Aber insgesamt gesehen ist eigentlich mein Appetit
in den Wochen und Tagen nicht so gut.
Aber keine Übelkeit?
Nein, keine Übelkeit und keine Erbrochen.
Eine neue Patiente, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte, darf ich?
Ja bitte.
Es geht um Frau Ingeborg-Bürtmann.
Sie ist 62 Jahre alt, 1 Meter, 68 groß und 80 kg schwer.
Frau Bürtmann steht bei uns seit 4 Wochen bestehende, zunehmende,
bis vor, vor.
Außerdem war bei ihr die folgende Begleichtsentente aufgefallen.
Sie muss 5 Mal Wasser lassen.
Sie hat in der letzten 4 Wochen 5 kg zugenommen.
Sie hat bei der Zeit die Beine ödemähen.
Sie hat die Fertigung, die Konzentration schwächer,
die Trocken-Gsärodermie.
Sie hat diese Dispno, die Sie erlaubt haben,
in letzter Zeit auch in Ruhe.
Sie sprachen eben schon von Orthopnoe.
Sie haben gesagt, okay.
Die Frage nach Nausee, Erbrochen, Fieber wurden verneint.
Sie berichtete zu dem, dass sie vor 6 Wochen
schwer COVID-19 Entzündung infiziert haben.
Sie haben schon einen Termin, Kardiologen.
Aber Sie könnten diese Bechwerden nicht aushalten.
Sie kommen bei uns.
Der Termin ist nicht beim Kardiologen, beim Hausarten.
Kardiologen war sie noch nie.
Sie haben schon recht.
Die Vorartranken sind bei ihr, die Vorargenden bekannt.
Artilleriehypertone seit 10 Jahren.
Da gegen Neemesie, Kardezarten 8 mg, morgens einmal und abends einmal.
Bis zur Projol 5 mg Tablet Neemesie, morgens und abends, total 2 mal.
Projol mit 50 mg Tablet Neemesie, morgens.
Sie haben auch gewettes Meditub 2 seit 2 Jahren.
Sie haben mit 800 g, morgens einmal und abends 1 halbe Tablet Neemesie.
Sie haben auch ihren Diet sehr gut beachten.
Sie haben ihren Blutzucker und ihren Riverokky sehr gut angestellt.
Sie haben auch 7 % Hemoglobin A1.
Die Medikamente, ich habe gesagt, die Voroperationen,
die Anamnese ergab,
sind die Ursprünger, die mit 9 Jahren operiert wurden.
Wir können sagen, im Alter von neun Jahren, Herr Neotomy,
Herr Neotomy, einer umbilikalernie.
Herr Neotomy ist die Bruchoperation und die Diagnose ist die umbilikalernie.
Sie wurde auch in Alter von zwölf Jahren wegen einer Tronsylektomie durchgeführt.
Ja, man kann sagen, im Alter von zwölf Jahren erfolgte eine Tronsylektomie.
Ja?
Und in Alter von 50 Jahren wurde sie auch eine Tronsylektomie erfolgt.
Ja, gab es, was war der Grund für die Tronsylektomie?
Ja, zuerst hat sie gesagt, eine akute Pankreatitis verdacht,
danach die Ursache Galenblasenentzündung.
Ja, es war wahrscheinlich ein Galengangstein,
der zu einer Begleit Pankreatitis geführt hat.
Ja.
Sie habe keine Allergie und keine Unfertigkeiten.
Noch die Genus mit einem Alkohol getrunken, aber nicht so viel.
Sie trinken nur noch wenig Alkohol nach der Pankreatitis.
Ja, seit Alter von 50 Jahren haben sie nur Angleichswan in der Woche getrunken.
Die Familienanalyse ergab, ihre Mutter leider an Asthma-Bromchale und beiseite Geonarthrosis.
Sie müssen mit dem Rollator laufen.
Sie sei 86 Jahre alt.
Ihr Vater ist leider ins Sufisienz, aber ist 76 Jahre alt gestorben.
Sagen Sie ruhig, der Vater ist mit 76 Jahren an Herz ins Sufisienz verstorben.
Ja, stimmt.
Sie haben auch ein Bruder, er sei 60 Jahre alt und leider auch gut Arturiel-Hypertoni.
Ja, als gynecologische Analyse, sie sei seit 3, 4 Jahren meiner Pause.
Sie lässt Besuche der Frauen aus, lässt Merz und alles in Ordnung.
Ja, danke.
Haben Sie zu Beginn bei der Patientin, Sie klagt über eine Orthopnöhe und Belastungsdispnöhe.
Haben Sie Anfangs die Vitalwerte kontrolliert, SBO2, Glutdruck, PKG?
Ja, Sie sind total licht.
Nach dem Gespräch habe ich Vitalparameter anschauen.
Also macht vielleicht sogar Sinn, schlage ich Ihnen vor ruhig bei so einer Patientin, die da sitzt.
Sie hat eine Orthopnöhe, sie sitzt vor Ihnen und bekommt schlecht Luft, dass Sie zu einem
einfach gleiche Beinrankt das messen, das ist glaube ich ganz hilfreich.
Ja, Sie sind total licht.
Gut, was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, Herzins Sufisienz.
Okay.
Ja, wegen dieser Orthopnöhe, Diesmöhe, Beinödemme und Sie haben auch rechtseitige Druck gefühlt,
das ist vielleicht herrpottomegalie, wegen dieser Herzschwäche.
Also, die Patientin, stimme ich Ihnen zu.
Also der Verdacht auf eine Herzins sufisienz oder man kann vielleicht sagen auf eine dekompensierte
Herzins sufisienz.
Im letzten zwei Tagen hat sie Orthopnöhe entwickelt.
Vorher war es vielleicht einer noch so eben kompensierte Herzins sufisienz, aber vielleicht
schon auf dem Weg zur Dekompensation.
Vielleicht ursächlich die schwere Covid-19 Erkrankung der Patientin.
Vielleicht Mikrokarditis oder Pericarditis.
Genau, es sollte eine begleitende Mikrokarditis gewesen sein, die dazu geführt hat, dass
jetzt die herzkardiale Situation sich verschlechtert hat.
Ja, weil sie hat gut angestellte Bluthochdrücke, Blutzucker, ihren Diet gut behalten,
deswegen arme Patienzen.
Also so ein bisschen spricht schon etwas für eine Dekompensation.
Dekompensation, ja.
Ich teile ihre Verdachtdiagnose.
Der Druckgefühl, was die Patientin beschreibt, kann wahrscheinlich eine Hepatobägerli sein.
Ein Stauungszeichen, würde ich das zumindest werden.
Eins haben Sie, Sie haben das sehr gut gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Da muss ich schon sagen, das war wirklich sehr gut.
Wir haben eine Sache vergessen, dem Ehemann ist irgendetwas aufgefallen.
Ja, Pseunose.
Eine Lippenzürenose.
Hier man vielwohl eine Lippenzürenose in den letzten Tagen auf.
Das fällt den Patienten oft selbst nicht so auf.
Die merken das oft nicht so, was an ihrem Äußeren passiert,
sondern den Angehörigen fällt das oft auf.
Anpägen, Hypoxie.
Anpägen hat eine jahrelange Hypertonie.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die Hypertonie vielleicht schon älter,
aber bis sie behandelt wird, dauert das ja oft leider.
Und das Herz hat irgendwann jetzt im Rahmen der Covid-Erkrankung
vielleicht dann doch noch eine zusätzliche Schädigung bekommen.
Und jetzt ist es eine dekompensierte Vorwiegend.
Jetzt wahrscheinlich Rechtsherzinsuffizienz,
wie das geschildert ist mit den Staungssymptomen,
mit den Odemen, mit der Nöktorie,
mit der Orthopnoe und der Hepatomegalie.
Gut, vielen Dank.
Ich danke dir.
Wir haben ja schon im Chat so ordentliche Hinweise darauf hin
mit Hepatomegalie und so weiter.
Rechtsinsuffizienz.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Und wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
9. Januar.
Wo?
Münster.
In Münster, in Westfalen.
Sehr schön.
Dann würde ich doch sagen, ich habe da ein sehr gutes Gefühl,
dass Sie die Prüfung gut machen.
Danke.
Sie haben auch die Fachbegriffe sehr gut gebracht
und haben nicht zu komplizierte Sätze gemacht.
Das gefällt mir immer gut.
Das bringt am wenigsten Schwierigkeiten.
Gut, dann wünsche ich Ihnen jetzt noch eine gute Vorbereitungszeit
auf die Prüfung.
Es ist ja nicht mehr lange hin.
Danke schön.
An die Gruppe sonst,
nächsten Donnerstag.